hello my friend hoi an
eu vim aqui falar pra vocês do você
aprende agora.com que é um curso de
inglês com aulas grátis online de três
minutos
desde o mais básico até o mais avançado
você aprende agora é um curso que nasceu
para que toda pessoa no mundo que queira
aprender inglês não importa quem seja
não importa onde esteja a prenda e de
preferência aprenda rápido com
eficiência e com aquilo que ele vá
utilizar em real life na vida real dele
bom eu vou contar para vocês aqui um
pouquinho da minha história com o inglês
e da evolução do você aprende agora até
agora nesses dois anos de existência de
você aprende agora eu eo inglês não
tínhamos uma relação muito amigável e o
espanhol sempre me encantou
mas o inglês era algo que eu não
conseguia falar e aí eu fazia um desses
cursos presenciais que por sinal custam
caro
até que chegou um dia que eu reprovei e
minha mãe falou meu filho a gente gasta
o dinheiro com você e você reprova você
não se dedica
eu falei olha mamãe eu copio a tarefa
chega lá eu durmo e quando perdem pra
mim repetiu até repito mas eu não
entendo nada
eu repito e aí ela me disse tudo bem meu
filho mas você precisa falar inglês nós
acreditamos que o inglês possa abrir
portas para você eu falei eu tenho uma
idéia qual que é a eu queria para a nova
zelândia
meus pais são super coruja super
apegados aos filhos e deixá-los é
sozinhos
é uma é um esforço muito grande de amor
por parte deles e eles disseram tudo bem
você pode até e mais você organiza a sua
viagem
tudo bem sem problemas fui comecei a
pesquisar e organizei minha viagem para
nova zelândia
e lá fui eu sofrer e passar um monte de
roubadas por que não sabia falar inglês
na verdade eu achava que eu sabe um
pouquinho cheguei lá meu amigo pessoal
perguntava é você prefere isso ou isso
aí eu não mas felipe evitou as perguntas
e prefere isso ou isso aí a pessoa não
for eu te perguntando a pessoa ficava
nesse gesto e eu pela mbari leite sabia
que a pessoa está mostrando uma coisa ou
outra e aí eu fechava a dona de 80
beleza passou eu formei ensino médio
nova zelândia comecei a trabalhar lá
trabalhei de aula de capoeira na escola
que eu estudei e trabalhei de jardineiro
pedreiro ela deixou a irlanda em um café
experiência fantástica
até que minha mãe me ligou um dia falou
meu filho chega né
embora pra casa a gente já está com
muita saudade de você acha que já está
bom
já tá falando inglês acho que é a hora
de voltar para casa sem problemas daqui
um mês
eu estou em casa e se deus quiser e aí
voltei ao brasil
voltei ao brasil já sabendo inglês né
pelo menos é tinha essa impressão e
comecei a cursar relações internacionais
mas concomitante ao curso de relações
internacionais
eu comecei a estagiar no centro de
idiomas e o coordenador do centro de
idiomas na época me convidou para fazer
parte da pós-graduação em ensino e
aprendizagem de língua inglesa e aquela
foi a oportunidade para mergulhar no
ensino e na aprendizagem de língua
inglesa
eu comecei a fazer essa pós-graduação
como aluno convidado
comecei a estudar muito e comecei a
entender como funciona o ensino e
aprendizagem da língua inglesa e comecei
a dar aula e aí meu amigo eu virei um
professor de inglês nem e as pessoas
encontravam comigo pessoas que eu não
via há muito tempo e felizmente está
dando aula de inglês cara e aí ficava
todo orgulhoso na aula de inglês
eu não sei vocês mas é eu sempre sempre
tive um sonho de ser milionário
e aí meu amigo eu comecei a trabalhar de
manhã à tarde à noite e de madrugada se
me convidassem para fazer qualquer uma
dessas
tarefas que eu fiz na nova zelândia e
que eu estava fazendo no brasil eu
estava pronto e aí comecei a trabalhar
me formei e comecei a fazer uma
pós-graduação estudar mas trabalhando
muito com o foco de fazer dinheiro e
fazendo uma coisa que me dava muito
tesão que ela dá aula de inglês
uma coisa que um aluno frustrado de
inglês estava fazendo agora mas com
subsídios teórico sabendo que estava
fazendo e utilizando algo que é é útil
na vida real
e aí aconteceu um imprevisto
eu estava fazendo uma viagem no interior
de mato grosso do sul e sofreu um
acidente de carro
e graças a deus esse acidente não me
aconteceu nada só alemão foi um acidente
super feio carro capotou várias vezes e
eu acho que não só eu falei eu preciso
agradecer a deus por esse milagre de ter
ficado viva mas como eu posso agradecer
a deus fazendo o que eu sei fazer porque
eu acredito que eu sei fazer bem feito
que dá aula de inglês e aí a gente
lançou você aprende agora e essa foi a
primeira aula
olá
hoje nós começamos o nosso curso inglês
pra você
o inglês pra você que está na frente do
computador e quer aprender como falar em
inglês
nós iniciamos a nossa primeira aula com
a expressão de como você começa uma
conversa oi
o inglês nós temos duas principais
expressões em long em ray e aí nós
gravamos 23 aulas
você aprende agora e 30 dias depois e
acontece isso aí eu sofri um acidente
hoje eu dou risada mas na primeira vez
que eu vi essa falta chorava o eu tinha
começado você aprende agora um mês
depois e aí eu falei chega com essa
loucura de trabalhar de viajar diz chega
deixa eu ficar quieta um pouco e aí meus
pais falaram fé ea gente vai pra ponta
porã que a fronteira sendo que com a
gente não vai trabalhar agora sábado era
uma sexta-feira
não tem problema podemos ir mas vocês na
frente que eu quero colocar um sonho meu
carro percebam que o carro de 30 dias
atrás era um carro bem melhor do que
esse
eu recebi o dinheiro do seguro e comprei
dois carros e chega de colocar dinheiro
em carro recebeu dinheiro seguro colocar
comprei dois carros e dois carros claro
óbvio bem mais simples e lógico não fiz
o seguro porque eu quando que um ser
humano vai imaginar que 30 dias depois
vai acontecer um negócio desses
gente essa aqui ó é minha mãe ela está
rezando aqui
para o bombeiro me tirar de dentro do
carro e eu vou falar pra vocês nesse
acidente aqui foi realmente um acidente
dava 60 quilômetros por hora
foi um acidente mas graças a deus que
aconteceu isso porque daí eu senti uma
coisa um chamado bem mais forte e aí
comecei a minha recuperação aí foi
fratura de costela
eu não achei nada no primeiro nem no
segundo fratura de fêmur fraturado de
calcâneo fratura na face e fratura de
costela e aí fui pra recuperação várias
cirurgias e vocês devem estar
então ele as aulas de inglês eu liguei
para o produtor e falei reginaldo até
hoje é ele que que gravar uma semana
passada estava em casa
reginaldo cara eu sofri um acidente ou
eu vi carciano jornal é louco cara eu
queria que ser gravar suas aulas pra mim
lá em casa
ele falou pra mim não tem problema
nenhum e ótimo e assim nós fizemos essa
cama que estou sentada na cama dos meus
pais foi onde entrou a marca quando eu
voltei do hospital eu não podia mexer da
cintura para baixo
então o que a gente fazia eu fiquei na
cama dos pais durante os três meses e aí
o regional do iel em casa ea gente
gravava as aulas do você aprende agora
lá em cima da cama os meus pais nós
gravamos mais de 500 aulas aí em cima
dessa cama até porque depois eu fui para
a cadeira de rodas comecei a andar mas o
costume agravada em cima daquela cama e
aí eu sentava ali falava terminar a
gravação levantar embora até avisar meus
pais hoje a gente vai fazer uma gravação
aqui é tranquilo meu filho pai e mãe né
pois bem aí a gente colocar esse pano
azul aí e nós seguimos as gravações e aí
a recuperação continua sendo é por
cadeira de rodas depois de cadeira de
rodas muletas depois bengala depois mais
uma cirurgia que acho que não deu muito
certo e eu já tô me conformando que foi
um acidente muito grave e eu se eu tenho
alguma dor hoje eu tenho que aprender a
viver com essa dor e vamos tocar a bola
pra frente que graças a deus foi um
milagre eu ter sobrevivido mas então a
gente começa em 2011
no final de 2011 se você aprende agora
em 2012 foi um ano muito significativo
porque o gustavo acabou de comentá eu
fui eleito pelo prêmio jovem
inspiradores na categoria voto popular o
jovem mais inspirador do brasil
não que eu seja mas isso deu muita
visibilidade para você aprende agora
então a gente ganha o prémio jovens
criadores e conclui o ano de 2012 com um
milhão de aula selecionadas pra gente do
brasil e do mundo ótimo
mas o que talvez o ponto chave do jovem
inspiradores foi na final na final nós
estávamos os dez jovens selecionados e
cada um tinha que apresentar fazer a sua
apresentação em 10 minutos no final
tinha uma sabatina de um dos maiores
empreendedores brasileiros e um deles o
beto sicupira me disse que o projeto é
muito bonito mas o dia que você parar de
trabalhar seu projeto mônica e lógico né
eu claro que ao invés de eu ficar quieto
tem humildade para ouvir e ficar quieto
não responde que o facebook o google não
cobram do usuário que não sei que não
sei quando mas o que aconteceu foi que
pouco depois eu percebi que ele tinha me
dito porque a grana que eu queria ser
milionário que tinha juntado já tinha
acabado e o dinheiro que eu ganho nas
universidades dando aula de inglês e
relações internacionais não eram
suficientes para tocar um projeto do
tamanho que tinha ficado você aprende
agora e aí nós lançamos o você aprende
agora.com a nossa plataforma própria
porque todas as aulas nossas são estão e
sempre estarão no youtube mas a gente
oferece agora as nossas aulas no nosso
site que oferece a aula a explicação e
para cada aula o aluno tem a opção de
responder 10 exercícios de múltipla
escolha ele vê os dez denunciados e se
ele tiver crédito que ele compra no site
a diga se de passagem
gastando 1 por cento do que gastaria em
qualquer outro curso
e se ele não tiver condições ele mandou
e mail eu coloco crédito para ele na
hora não tem problema nenhum
bom e ele tem essas 10
ele tem sido um exercício de múltipla
escolha e clique em cima responder às
perguntas abrem quatro alternativas para
4 alternativa
ele responde e automaticamente o site
corrigir para ele todo você aprende
agora está construído dentro de um
conceito de edutainment em que o aluno é
faz as aulas responde os exercícios e
ganha pontos entra no ranking nós
estamos lançando um sistema de bege
ora tudo pra que ele aprenda mais melhor
e mais rápido ea metodologia é de 10
minutos por aula o aluno nossas aulas
têm em média três minutos o aluno nós
dizemos aluno assista cada aula três
vezes
primeiro você entende depois você
escreve tudo e por último você repete na
frente da tela e responde os exercícios
primeiro você vai entender o que estou
dizendo depois você vai escrever tudo
por último você vai repetir na frente da
tela pode ser do seu celular do tablet
do computador de onde você estiver
a hora que você quiser e aí você
responde às 10 perguntas do site
as aulas leccionadas mas as histórias em
2012 nós fechamos o ano com 1 milhão de
aula selecionados nesse momento nós
estamos com 2.9 milhões de aula
selecionadas e américa a meta para 2013
e atingir 3 milhões
nós acreditamos que em duas semanas nós
já batemos a nossa meta mas o que vale
um número 3 milhões de aulas sem as
histórias que existem por trás desses
números
as histórias que fazem valer são as
histórias que fazem você acordar e falar
vou continuar com isso vale a pena e tem
muitas histórias eu trouxe algumas aqui
é no celular
se eu pego aqui prá lá e prá vocês
comentários que nos chegam e mails que
não chegam todos os dias
alguns aqui não pensei que iria aprender
inglês com uma aula na internet vou
compartilhar parabéns você aprende agora
ela o felipe o professor em uma escola
estadual e tem utilizado seus vídeos em
minhas aulas
um outro que talvez seja o comentário
mais recorrente e é sair dele que é uma
aula de símbolo para 5 pés que a gente
pergunta de um dos assistentes
eles cometem essa é a idéia do professor
quero te agradecer pelo seu curso de
inglês estou com vergonha mas tem que
falar
o amor da minha vida indiano e era muito
difícil nossa comunicação agora está
melhor
não cometi isso com ninguém tá não falei
o nome tom preservando a aluna
o caso mais simbólico você aprende agora
são várias as histórias caso mais
simbólico
ora chama-se ana hartog a ana não fala
português
eu coloquei a história dela justamente
algumas horas atrás porque eu coloquei
pessoal daqui a pouco estarei no texo
unisinos você tem alguma história com
você aprende agora e ela comentou eu vou
ler pra vocês que acho que tá ruim a
leitura haiti ele pediu vista e se
estranha a ser um ano e meio decidiu que
queria aprender inglês tenha desceu e
adicione tenha que decidir como e onde
ademar sem pensar assim o irã não seria
fácil teria que ser consequente dedicada
news que ela encontre seus vídeos no
youtube e em português do brasil
não foi um bom começo cada vídeo repetiu
várias vezes 08 e larry birns sair um
diálogo ele formatou inglês para uma
aluna arma de caça e maior já que tenho
55 anos e se você aprender agora em
curso olhar para conseguir o objetivo
se aprendendo e comentário imediato do
professor e sua motivação diária caminho
a conseguir o objetivo
muito obrigado a você aprende agora
agora nós temos estamos indo muito bem
em termos de acesso em termos de impacto
em termos financeiros que nós estamos
crescendo cada vez mais e não tenho
dúvida vamos atingir a sustentabilidade
financeira
mas o próximo passo que tem sido um
passo muito difícil para mim é entrar
nas escolas públicas do brasil eu já
ofereci você aprende agora pago eu já
ofereci você aprende agora barato e já
ofereceu você aprende agora grátis pra
pessoas que queiram colocar você aprende
agora escolas públicas graças à
plataforma disponível sem nenhum custo
eu ainda não encontrei isso no meu país
mas veja como são as coisas
eu tenho visitado alguns países a
convite de alguns países e nós já
estamos lançando você atua aprender essa
hora em outros países da américa latina
que tem gente que viu o valor que tenho
que fazer
olá como essa o emprestamos do curso de
inglês do aprendiz agora pensamos na
primeira classe como commercio
olá você acha que eu estou de
brincadeira mas é sério
já gravamos dez salas e vamos jogar
ainda mais a rede semana passada eu
estava no méxico
o pessoal falou pra mim filipe começam
ontem foi agravando as três primeiras
horas mas eu preciso de 100 calma se eu
voltar primeiro a gente grava mas já
estamos gravando agora vamos 10 semana
que vem vou gravar mais 10
estamos lançando sua prenda hora no
américa na américa latina inteira então
players e filmando o hotel in hell com o
implemento você aprende agora do palco
exclusivo vai cantar e muito obrigado
tem que haver debate ele pediu esse nexo